médiathèque salle de spectacle lieu
d'exposition la culture occupe une place
de choix dans la vie des 5 continents et
aujourd'hui il faut être encore plus
accessible à tous elle se décline selon
des thèmes communs dans les équipements
de l'agglo et à l'ère du deux points 0
et là le compte est bon je me comprends
ces deux points parce qu'en fait deux
points 0 tu dis parce que je te parle
d'Internet en fait tu comprends pas de
ce que je voulais dire
favoriser la diversité l'innovation
culturelle mais également l'acquisition
et le partage des savoirs voici les
priorités de l'agglo quand elle crée de
nouveau service culturels implantés sur
les sept communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le réseau des
médiathèques qui dispose déjà d'une
collection de 549 753 documents
bénéficie ainsi de nouveaux outils
numériques
c'est le nouveau nom du portail des
médiathèques
c'est un service en ligne sur internet
qui permet de consulter notre catalogue
et qui permet beaucoup d'autres services
et ça a été mis en place au début de
l'été on peut consulter son compte
faire des réservations on peut prolonger
ces documents
on peut voir ce que les médiathèques
possèdent en livre vidéo etc mais on
peut maintenant avoir des ressources
numériques donc on peut télécharger des
livres numériques et on peut surtout se
former grâce à des vidéos en ligne ce
qu'on propose pour l'instant ce sont des
vidéos pour apprendre à utiliser tous
les outils informatiques d'aujourd'hui
donc ça peut être le programme classique
tels que les traitements de texte etc
mais les choses plus pratiques dans la
vie de tous les jours gérer son appareil
photo sa musique
télécharger l'année prochaine en 2014
nous allons mettre en ligne de nouveaux
outils de formation
numérique notamment des possibilités de
cours de langue des cours par exemple
pour se former pour le permis de
conduire et tout un programme
d'accompagnement de son enfant pendant
sa scolarité
on peut surveille médiathèque aussi
quand on voit un document qui nous
intéresse un livre ou une musique qu'on
a entendu à la radio on se dit est-ce
que la médiathèque le possède oui mais
c'est à médiathèque qui a l'autre bout
de 5 ans j'ai pas envie d'y aller c'est
compliqué je peux le faire venir dans la
médiathèque qui est où je me rends
habituellement à côté de chez moi sur
place dans les lieux on a on propose
maintenant le wifi gratuit donc toute
personne qui est inscrite dans les
médiathèques peut se connecter
des liseuses avec des livres numériques
chargés sont également à votre
disposition en prêt et si vous voulez
être sûr de ne pas oublier de rendre vos
documents petits étourdis va sachez
aussi que de nouvelles solutions
existent une des innovations du
printemps c'est que au lieu de recevoir
un courrier chez soi quand on est des
documents en retard ou une réservation
qui est arrivée maintenant on peut le
recevoir par mail ou par SMS c'était vos
choix c'est beaucoup plus rapide autre
nouveauté numérique et culturelle de
taille la possibilité depuis le site du
kiosque d'accéder à NBA tri en ligne
mutualisé pour acheter toutes vos places
de spectacle à 50 ans en Yvelines ça
s'appelle kiosque la billetterie
alors il faut savoir que kiosque la
billetterie bien sûr on l'associe à
kiosque kiosque le site de référence de
la vie culturelle à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais à
saint-quentin-en-y on a une
particularité c'est qu'on a une très
très belle programmation de spectacle de
la danse du théâtre de la musique du
jazz du cirque et qu'on a une offre
importante pour tous les âges et le
projet de la billetterie commune c'est
qu'à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
maintenant en quelques clics on pourra
acheter ces places de spectacle sur le
site sur une plateforme de billetterie
avec un panier unique pour pouvoir
acheter un moteur de recherche pour
trier selon ses goûts ses envies l'âge
de ses enfants portés par la Communauté
d'Agglomération en partenariat avec la
plupart des salles de spectacles du
territoire la billetterie kiosque vous
permet ainsi d'accéder après de 400
spectacles en seulement quelques clics
c'est une innovation parce qu'après très
très peu de lieux d'agglomération de
territoires en France qui proposent ce
service profitez de la culture à 50 ans
en Yvelines n'aura donc jamais été aussi
simple mais au fait quel est programme
il paraît qu'il est réuni en ce qui
concerne les équipements de la bio selon
quatre thématiques c'est vrai ça
Véronique Balbo Bonneval et pourquoi
d'abord pour montrer que les
propositions artistiques nous faisons
ont du sens qu'elle permet de partager
une culture de de se projeter dans
l'avenir de vivre des choses ensemble et
de témoigner de ce que l'on vit
certains d'octobre partageons nos
cultures on se crée une culture commune
tous les équipements y participent des
agglomération
Novembre Décembre racontons nos
histoires parce que il faut regarder au
travers du prisme de l'expérience de
chacun mars avril inventons demain parce
qu'il faut quand vraiment qu'on rêve
l'Avenir Ensemble à travers les
spectacles les propositions d'actions
culturelles et mes joints exprimons nos
talents parce que tout ce que chacun va
faire au point de vue atelier toute
l'année à pouvoir être présenté dans
l'espace public pour créer un grand
rituel collectif et il est temps fort
alors quelques pistes sur les événements
importants ou à venir déjà sur toute
l'année une offre jeune public partagée
entre tous les équipements du territoire
pour le coup l'ensemble des équipements
des communes et de l'agglomération donc
plus de 90 spectacles pour lequel vous
avez un programme Jeune Public de la
saison jeune public la fête du conte en
décembre novembre la fête de la science
au sein de partageons nos cultures la
semaine du développement durable sur la
thématique invent et pulsations urbaine
c'est les 30 ans du hip-hop et
l'ensemble du territoire de
l'agglomération et tous les acteurs de
culturels participent à faire une
vaste opération autour du hip-hop
et maintenant qu'on sait bien cultivé on
sait bien cultivé Michael ouais
et en début de ses actus avec une belle
info puisqu'on est rendait le groupement
girondicap et inauguré une salle ou une
professionnelle formée mettra en
pratique la méthode Snoezelen auprès des
personnes reçues dans le cadre de
l'accueil de jour Seigneur via la
stimulation des sens l'objectif est
apporté plaisir des tentes et apaisement
avec de très bons résultats
ça y est le 18 septembre la salle des
pas perdus de la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux nous dévoilait
son nouveau visage rénovation du hall
plus de luminosité signalétique adapté
nouveau commerce circulation optimisée
renforcement de l'accessibilité pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite que du plus
que du mieux ça roule quoi et puisque ça
roule nous ne pouvions faire l'impasse
sur la ligne de bus numéro 16 qui relie
Saint-Quentin à Poissy et Cergy afin
d'assurer au voyageur des liaisons
directes et confortables et éviter les
surcharges en gare de Poissy 11 cours ce
supplémentaires ont en effet été ajoutés
depuis le 2 septembre en matinée et en
fin d'après-midi
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit Quentin du mois d'octobre
avec également un article sur les
emplois à David et un autre sur un
potager dans la ville un article qui va
vous redonner la patate et la pêche